Oh Kenosha ma Island is a short 12
minute ferry ride from her Oshima region
of Japan while the sandy and palm-lined
beaches are perfect for holiday makers
the island draws crowds for a different
reason
rabbits lots of oh and how they got
there is a mystery between 1929 1945 the
Japanese army secretly produced over
6,000 tons of poison gas on Okinawa
Island
some believe the current rabbits are
descendants of those brought to the
island to test the gas but the current
director of the poison gas museum
insists these bunnies have nothing to do
with those from the world war ii era so
where did they come from
you don't know shaggy oh no shaggy we
don't necessary to get on this you know
more one theory a cocoon excitin 3d
polite and wasps think you can imagine
any demo today gatita for the Catena
Saki naka de uno momento de artists
money mata Mata ki muscle
so those rabbits were released and with
no real predators they bred like well
like rabbits and yet another theory
Sagi 100 Mario - I see kawaii
today I know conquering not that opening
was a yokai hajimeta
so today Amano Okinawa de top some
creative me the Conqueror call your
karate muscle so you joke about it yeah
either way this new generation of feral
rabbits has the run of the land they're
creating a new story separate from the
sordid past of Okinawa Island and Alan
once known for death is now known for
possibly the cutest thing ever
bunnies
you